hello and welcome to the session best
practices for block storage on Google
cloud my name is Reuben
and I'm a product manager on compute
engine team and today I have some
exciting new developments and blog
storage to share with you Before we jump
in I have a short safe harbor statement
the purpose of this presentation is to
provide better visibility into our
current product plans and contains
forward-looking statements while we
strive to meet the timelines you will
see this is not an official commitment
but our current best estimate products
on a roadmap and any products an early
release are not guaranteed to become
generally available or maybe
significantly modified from their
current form in this session we'll see
an overview of block storage on Google
cloud with details of what is new this
year we cover available disk types and
discuss how the new disk types fit into
the product family we then dive deeper
into how to select the right disk types
for your workloads to better optimize
performance and cost finally we'll cover
some details of how throttling and
performance works for block storage
ending with some simple best practices
this year we're expanding or persistent
disk product portfolio with two new
desktops balance PD is our
general-purpose disk best suited for
enterprise applications and for the
highest performance workloads such as s
AP HANA and other high end in-memory
data bases were introducing extreme PD
at the same time all of our existing dis
types are seeing substantial increases
in performance this year we have
increased the maximum sustained read I
opted for zonal this is deep persistent
disks you can now issue a hundred
thousand miles per second up from sixty
thousand previously I hope sensitive
workloads should see substantial
benefits from this increase we've also
increased the maximum sustained
throughput for zonal persistent disks
from twelve hundred megabytes reads and
foreigner megabytes writes five times
the sustained read throughput enables
cost effective implementation of large
scale throughput intensive workloads
such as Hadoop some workloads are
optimized for TCO others need every bit
of performance they can get Google
compute engine now offers a wider
spectrum of disk types to match your
workload needs providing you with the
same flexibility that our VM families
already offer with
nudists types you can pick the right
price performance profile for your
workload storage needs let's look at
some of these changes a little more
closely generally available this month
balance PD is our new general-purpose
disk for Google compute engine
it offers SSD performance and represents
an over 40% saving compared to
performance PD offering the lowest TCO
over general-purpose workloads balanced
PD has the right performance for most
enterprise apps web servers and even
some small and medium databases
it also offers many of the same advanced
features you already know from
performance PD you can create regional
or zonal volumes and you can attach
multiple instances to single volume and
lead only mode balanced PD replaces
standard PD as the new general-purpose
disk with six I ops per gigabyte and a
maximum 80,000 sustain I ops
it offers significantly higher
performance and more performance per
dollar
in fact we're the right heavy read heavy
or in-between balanced PD offers two
times the eye ops per dollar for most
use cases or better this means that
despite the higher and cost per gigabyte
for many workloads balanced PD can
actually to improve TCO when you take
into account the impact of faster
performance at the workload level end to
end this can express itself in the form
of cost savings from faster task
completion for example reduced data
broadcasts or in the reduced need to
size - I ops rather than pure capacity
performance PD is a new name for PD SSD
as it continues to evolve and focus on
performance sensitive workloads this
year we have already increased VI ops
from 60,000 to 100,000 and this month
we're following this up by increasing
writer ops for zonal performance PD from
30,000 to 100,000 as well similarly this
month we are also increasing write
throughput from 800 to 1,200 megabytes
per second and so zonal performance PD
will have full rewrite parity coming
forward customers running data bases
with right heavy workloads should see
noticeable improvements in performance
from a three-fold increase in right eye
ops and 50% improvement and right
throughput and performance PD continues
to have the best price Priam's we will
also continue to add more advanced
features to performance PD and
20:21 in addition to the existing multi
reader feature we will offer a multi
writer feature on this desktop we expect
to have this ready for preview later
this year for use cases that need more
eye ops or more throughput and
performance PD offers we're introducing
extreme PD extreme PD is our new disk
type for high-end performance critical
applications it has been designed with s
AP Hana and other high-end in-memory
databases in mind at launch
it'll offer 120 thousand provision die
ops and 2.4 gigabytes a second of
maximum sustained throughput extreme PD
introduces provision dye ops allowing
you to provision capacity and
performance separately provision dye ops
are specified at disc creation and then
can be changed dynamically at any time
allowing you to adjust disk performance
to the specific requirements of your
workload over time next year there will
also be explicit performance as a Lay's
for provision items extreme PD is
preview available this month and general
availability is expected to follow in
the third quarter finally we've also
continued to improve local SSD local SSD
now offers more than three times the AI
ops 2.4 million read and 1.2 million
write AI ops and local SSD now supports
9 terabytes of three-fold increase in
maximum capacity for flash optimized
databases performance sensitive
analytics or hot caches local SSD now
offers industry-leading performance per
dollar for local storage with the new
disk types and improved performance for
existing disk types you can pick the
right price performance profile for your
workload let's have a quick look at
choosing the right disk type for many
workloads three criteria helped to
quickly identify a good starting point
for the right disk top firstly what does
the price performance profile look like
what are your workloads i/o and
throughput requirements how sensitive is
the workload to storage scale and cost
second what are the availability and
durability requirements if the workload
is replicating data across instances is
this being handled at the app database
or storage layer finally what storage
capacity
we'll be needed looking at performance
in a bit more detail the right price and
bright price performance by workload
depends on the desktop the exact
performance requirements will of course
vary for each specific workload but in
general the type of workload will be
good indicator of which disk type is
likely to be a good fit workloads that
are performance critical that depend on
the highest available throughput and/or
I ops and need durability are likely
best served by extreme PD an example of
this might be in memory databases I ops
driven performance sensitive workloads
like most larger databases or a good fit
for performance PD performance PDA
offers the best price pre-ops
balanced PD offers substantially lower
TCO than performance PD and offers the
right performance for web serving line
of business and IT apps finally standard
PD is likely a good fit for throughput
oriented cost sensitive workloads with
substantial capacity requirements such
as for example a dupe or Kafka similarly
durability and availability requirements
will vary by workload as it is ephemeral
local SSD is a good option for stateless
workloads where application is managed
at the app or database layer zonal
persistent disk is of course durable
it also supports snapshots which can be
saved to a different region for geo
redundancy for mission critical
workloads that need to meet very low
recovery point objectives and recovery
time objectives regional persistent disk
provides a highly available option
regional PD offers our PL 0 for single
failures an RTO less than a minute at a
disc level of course the storage
requirements may not apply uniformly to
entire workloads sometimes different
needs within a workload are best met by
different disk types for example for
sequel server instance you might
leverage the higher I opt lower latency
in lower cost of local SSD for temp DB
which doesn't need to be persistent and
have the data on performance or even
extreme PD for analytics pipeline you
might have source and output data on the
Google Cloud storage while the
intermediate data that's produced by one
state
your pipeline and consumed by the
another might be a persistent disk or
local SST to achieve higher performance
using different disk types with an
instance has interesting performance
implications let's have a look at
understanding disk performance in a bit
more detail persistent disk performance
dependent this type disk size instance
type in size in this example I have an N
2 standard instance with 64 V CPU that
can support a maximum of a hundred
thousand items our performance PDA
volume is sized to three terabytes and
at 30 miles per gigabyte that results in
90,000 miles if my workload benefits
from having access to the 400,000 iOS I
could get there by increasing the size
of the volume correspondingly on the
other hand if I were to create a
balanced PD of the same size instead the
volume would have $18,000 for some
existing workloads disks are sized to
reach I Ops requirements vs. fulfilling
capacity needs for these workloads
especially if they are on PD standard
disks the introduction of balanced PDE
might change the equation throughput for
performance PD and balanced PD is full
duplex workloads can use twelve hundred
megabytes read and 1200 megabytes right
concurrently on the other hand I ops
pulled from the same budget so read I
OPS+ write oblems hit the same hundred
thousand or eighty thousand limit for
performance PD or balanced PD
respectively disks of the same type
count by total capacity regardless of
volume one disk of three terabyte or two
disks of the same total capacity behave
the same way
in this example my two disks add up to
the same capacity that previously
provisioned and I will continue to have
ninety thousand ions under contention
the IUP's are split evenly across the
volumes regardless of size if your
workload has specific requirements for
sub components or tasks control the eye
ops consumption at the workload level PG
disks of different types consume the
same instance level I ops and throughput
budget
in this example I've added a standard PD
disc to the instance and I now have to
watch for smaller jobs in PD standard
consuming I ops or throughput during
spikes for the performance PD bound
workload local SSD in persistent disk do
not share in I observe throughput limit
let's have a look at some best practices
and pitfalls that we commonly see disks
smaller than 500 gigabytes have a boost
feature this allows them to boost the
performance to that of a 500 gigabyte
drive for short periods of time for the
most predictable performance size disks
to be at least 500 gigabytes in larger
scale out workloads and in some
workloads that migrated from on-premise
we sometimes see persistent disk uses if
it weren't durable in other words
workloads sometimes rebuild data disks
for nodes after instance or node failure
and in these cases seeing if rebuilding
the data disks is really needed might
result in substantial performance
improvements for large nodes this can
turn minutes or even hours of recreating
data discs in two seconds of reattaching
to the existing disk as we just learned
local SSD instance limits are separate
from persistent disk instance limits
pairing it up allows PD to achieve
higher performance for example using
local SSD a scratch space can move I ops
from PD volumes hitting instance I ops
limits or run the workload and local SSD
with a replica or backup in PD finally I
want to cover peak vs. average
performance and throttling workloads
with spikes will see throttle I ups
and/or bites even while average
performance is not hitting the maximum
of the instance or volume you'll see
this by average meters showing
performance below what you would see as
a maximum but potentially peak showing
values that are much higher this is
because average meters cover one-minute
intervals while peak is a point in time
measure what this means is that for
these workloads there are often two
different ways of achieving better
performance you could increase the I ops
for the volume for example by changing
Kappa
this type or incidence type or it might
be possible to smooth out the spikes of
requests coming from the workload if
feasible the ladder can achieve the same
end result without increasing the
resources required and hence the TCO of
the workload and that concludes our
session today covering best practices
for block storage on Google cloud with
balanced PD and extreme PD we have
introduced two new disk types that
fundamentally change the price
performance profile for general-purpose
and performance critical workloads
respectively and together with the
substantial improvements in performance
with existing disk types you can now
pick the right disk for your workload
matching the flexibility you already had
with our VM families thank you